somebody else without plenty of daddy
drama is made Markel but the Duchess is
focused on her royal duties and starting
a family of Rome today we got a look at
the Duchess with dogs
Megan paid a solo visit to an ammo
charity for her six month baby buck was
clad in a beige knit dress from H&M that
cost under $35 her heels were so high
that she actually looked a bit wobbly on
her feet at one point yes she did touch
her bump she looked absolutely delighted
to be meeting quite a few rescue dogs
including a little Jack Russell called
Minnie who was up for adoption today the
pregnant Oriole was all smiles despite
constant press reports that she's
measurable in her new royal role I was
there with her today she certainly
doesn't look miserable of course she's
an actress she could be failing the
whole thing but my sources tell me that
actually behind the scenes her and Harry
are really happy at the moment making
showed off her a sense of humor when a
well-wisher said this to her Duchess
Kate also made the solo appearance today
checking out costumes at the Royal Opera
House and there continues to be reports
that's so much public interest in vagin
may have caused a rift with Kate yes
it's ruffled the feathers of a few
quarters possibly Kate does feel a
little eclipsed by Megan but clearly
there have been tensions and I think it
was hoped that by appearing as a force
and this Christmas everyone would stop
talking about these rumours of a royal
food they haven't really gone away come
on Kate is like take all the attention
girls at all
[Music]